this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the global brand for men's
grooming and hygiene products
this month i am reading every single
chapter of chainsaw man every day i get
sent thousands of requests to cover
different anime however chainsaw man
caught my eye because of the excitement
surrounding it before its anime has ever
hit the airwaves last week we covered
the first three arcs of the story it was
epic if you haven't yet seen that click
the link up in the top right but to cut
a long story short i set out on this
journey initially to see if the hype
surrounding chainsaw man was justified
and upon finishing last week's material
i could safely say that there's more
than enough promise and polish in the
story to make the claim that this could
be the next big thing the only question
remaining being can tatsuki fujimoto
keep it up well let's see part two of
the review starts now
[Music]
before we dive into this week's video i
want to share with you something our
team's been working on i very rarely
release any merch but we've fallen in
love with chainsaw man and wanted to
design our very own devil character i
reveal to you manga man this epic design
was inspired by all the different
instruments that helped bring our
favorite stories to life i love this
design and it's now available in
t-shirts hoodies crew necks you name it
the last time i put out new merch it
didn't last too long so if you want to
secure your design follow the link
beneath this video or in the description
katana devil arc alright so the last
time we visited the story i had some
strong suspicions concerning makima and
then boom she got shot in the head so
now i don't really know what to think
which along with the way the story is
paneled is by far its best attribute the
way the last arc ended had me gagging to
see how this continued and to be honest
there were some really interesting
developments that totally took me by
surprise yet again we've gotten hints
about this particular angle towards the
end of the last act but every villain or
devil that denzin the corporation he
fights for faces off against seems to
have the same underlying mission driving
them in the direction of denji to steal
his heart and right as makima was taken
out by those yakuza thugs denji gets
shot in the face by another member of
this unit in the middle of a restaurant
with aki power and himeno present this
is the first chapter of this video i'm
reviewing and already we have some
heart-stopping action and wonderfully
kinetic paneling by fujimoto that helps
the scene really come to life this page
specifically when power jumps into
action is brilliant at conveying her
motion all the while leading elegantly
and naturally into aki's big attack
everything about this scene feels
desperate and out of nowhere himino is
down for the count power is hamstrung
trying to help her stay alive by
managing her blood supply denji is out
called from being shot in the face and
aki is struggling to stay alive against
this new enemy someone that we thought
was a human but one that turned out to
be this arc's titular antagonist katana
man or perhaps i'm speaking with
unfounded certainty okay so theory time
now i know what you're thinking mark
what do you mean surely this is the bad
guy he's got a knife for a face and okay
look i hear you don't worry he probably
is a bad guy to some extent but briefly
something i feel less confident about
with this story the longer i read it for
is in fact the judgment of the main
character himself and fujimoto's
awareness of how a reader or perhaps
myself might be feeling at this time
reading the story at the beginning of
this tale the first arc establishes of
course the core components of the story
pochetta the only thing in this world
that denji loved physically becomes
denji's heart transforming him into the
chainsaw man vowing henceforth to
achieve his dream in the name of his
lost companion sacrifice this is
something anyone can get behind however
in making this rather traditional
narrative setup fujimoto also snuck in a
rather ambiguous dream for denji to
shoot for which ultimately colours all
of denji's choices moving forward in the
story he wants to lead the most
fulfilling life he can conceive of which
as it happens is a goal which transforms
more than denji does in this story with
that said i like denji despite him being
down for the count right now all the
while hayakawa rises in the ranks and
becomes my new favorite character i mean
seriously this guy is cold with that
said concerning denji i like the rest of
you reading along are wishing for him to
achieve his dream and due to that
dream's ambiguity we sort of get
co-opted into hoping that whatever form
denji's dream takes ultimately gets
achieved it's natural for the reader to
root for the main character however
fujimoto is honestly making me
second-guess myself here if this was any
other story i would have felt
comfortable looking ahead but for the
first time in a long time reading a
manga i'm starting to feel uneasy when i
consider what denji is in fact reaching
for similar to how hunter hunter made me
reconsider and analyze the goal of gone
more closely in chainsaw men while each
arc seems to have denji pulled in
different directions for one reason or
another with him learning to love and
connect with other people in his life no
matter what he always comes back
to makima in other words i feel like
tatsuki fujimoto is leveraging the
tropes and cliches of manga to guide his
readers down a particular path like
hansel and gretel we're being lulled
into a false sense of security and
hoping that denji finally connects to
and lives happily ever after with makima
however in reality i feel that something
much much more severe is on the horizon
for this guy and perhaps down the road
it'll all explode in his face pawn
definitely intended but not for this arc
it's the next one but i guess what i'm
trying to say is that both literally and
metaphorically on both sides of this war
the gun devil and his minions versus
makima and her agency are all fighting
for control over denji's heart without
any regard for who dies in the process
and speaking of which i i was going to
call this a battle but really it's more
of an ambush you feel that in the
desperation of everyone involved on the
side of denji particularly through the
likes of aki whipping out his sword
without regard for the very consequences
we learned of in the prior arc and most
impactfully himeno this is once again a
story of contrast in the same way the
designs betray and work to complement
the actions and personalities of these
characters kimino's self the sacrifice
of herself to prolong the life of the
person she loves and aki is contrasted
starkly by the devil she enlists the
help of this beautifully altruistic
action is set alongside the utterly
terrifying and grotesque looking ghost
of hers once she gives her body up for
it truly the stuff of nightmares which
i'm sure has led many a reader to ask
themselves how in the name of all that
is holy did chainsaw man get serialized
in shonen jump apart from the graphic
violence there's also a hefty amount of
sexually explicit content okay i i say
explicit but i mean explicit for a 12
year old which is the demographic that
the magazine is targeting but who knows
maybe times are changing but yeah
everyone seems to be after denji's heart
and only denji is left to defend himself
after ximena gave him that chance as her
parting final gambit so many people in
this agency have died or on the verge of
dying but
makima has other plans
last time i said that this girl was
scary now i'm saying that this girl
terrifies me to my core systematically
and in retaliation to the accused that
attacked her and her agency she
sacrifices person after person atop this
weird monastery or shrine area and in
doing so turns a ton of yakuza targets
into popped blood balloons remotely from
god knows how far away this feels like
the most otherworldly godlike power
we've seen in this series and i wonder
if this is any connection to the gun
devil itself the gun devil is clearly
targeting her and her agency but for
what reason exactly i do not yet know it
could be something as simple as they're
the ones targeting the gun devil but i
feel like there might be more to that
but who knows what i do know is that
makima seems to be among those targeted
first is this because she's the most
dangerous i mean it sure seems to be the
case but moreover i wonder what else we
don't know about this increasingly
interesting and suspect agency denji is
working for the conflict on the ground
with denji and what's left of his team
is brought to a swift resolution as this
weird kid and katana man make their
strategic retreat i'll only touch on
this for a moment but i have to say
something here because apparently i'm a
massive sim for fujimoto's layouts look
at how stupidly easy it is to read this
layout look how naturally our eyes
follow this page with kobani on the
sixth and seventh pages of chapter 28.
look at how each panel guides your eyes
to the next one in the sequence
effortlessly creating this sense of
movement without movement at all this is
the stuff i live for for those of you
that know how much i love and hold
dragon balls manga in high regard
concerning its layouts i think i'm ready
to say the chainsaw man for me so far is
on par with that series this is
incredible work
no also last time i touched on manscape
i spoke about how they launched the
fancy lawnmower 4.0 but did you know you
can now get all that and more with their
brand new performance package 4.0 bundle
with a nose and ear trimmer in their new
weed whacker it really is the perfect
all-in-one grooming kit for the sake of
ease i'm sure most of us would like to
do our grooming in the shower and so
thankfully the lawnmower 4.0 makes that
possible thanks to its 100 cordless and
waterproof design it also comes with
replaceable ceramic blades to maintain
that lovely skin safe sharpness for as
long as possible after you get yourself
all trim and proper it's important to
keep your skin feeling great with
manscape's crop preserver ball deodorant
just a dollop of this quick absorbing
clear drying lotion will keep you
protected all day and hey if you feel a
little musky throughout the day there's
also the crop reviver ball toner spray
to revitalize your dangly bits and when
all is said and done just plonk the
lawnmower into its handy wireless
charging dock and be on your way it's as
simple as that head over to manscape.com
today and get 20 off free international
shipping and two free gifts with your
purchase your balls and your body will
thank you
speaking on akihakawa for just a moment
within both this arc and the next one he
acts as the heartbeat or emotion of the
story speaking on this arc specifically
particularly following the initial fight
with katanaman despite almost losing his
life he focuses instead on what he's
lost which quite elegantly highlights
what makes his character a wonderful
contrast with the likes of denji again
causing denji himself to feel that
discrepancy between him and aki also
however in reality denji too has
something aki should want that is to
live denji is happy with his lot in life
and numerous times he alludes to this
reality in the story it's a wonderful
powerful feeling for a character to have
he's happy that he's alive every single
day whereas a large part of aki's story
concerns him being tortured by his
decisions as he tirelessly marches like
a soldier day in day out towards his
death in other words denji seems to be
willing to do anything to maintain the
best life he can possible whereas aki
seems to be tirelessly in search of his
way out in pursuit of his own goal
within this arc there's a great emphasis
on flashbacks exploring the first
meeting and budding friendships with
himino set alongside sprawling page
layouts where he demonstrates what she
meant to him both in action and in quiet
contemplation this character aki and
really these scenes demonstrate a strong
conviction that it's trying to
communicate as worthy of throwing
everything away in attempting to reach
said goal but i'm sure regarding aki
i'll have more of a chance to talk about
that in the next arc that said all of
this has been quite emotionally heavy
and action-packed so next up is probably
my favorite part of this particular arc
the training beanie arc now that it's
become known the gun devil is after
denji's heart for some yet unknown
reasons makima has seen it necessary to
enroll both power and deji himself into
training to hone their respective
abilities and powers it also acts as a
nice tune-up for everyone reading along
to see what makes each of these
characters take physically and someone
emotionally prior to accepting them as
pupils or playthings as he calls them
later on this rather intimidating
individual asks power and denji a set of
questions probing their individual
morality after some necessary preamble
where this scary lad demonstrates his
strength and knowledge of their
physiology he gives power and dengy a
chance to attack and upon a moment's
notice the teamwork between the two is
apparent and while power matching
forward without hesitation can be
chalked up to her fiend status and
really her character in general denji's
zero hesitation seems somewhat chilling
to me which again makes me think back to
the metaphor that's constantly being
thrown around to describe what denji is
to both makima and her agency that he's
akin to a dog dogs at least to me aren't
born killers but they can be trained to
be and denji seems to have lived a life
that has sculpted him into this person
or ort makiba is slowly turning him into
someone that cannot value human life
like aki can who is by the way someone
we have now learned has lost the power
to wield his fox spirit in battle jew to
how reckless he was being in the battle
with katana man signifying perhaps that
even a literal canine spirit couldn't
comfortably do what the devil agency
expects aki to do this is an agency that
sees their employees as necessary and
probable collateral damage aki
specifically demonstrates this with
their offer to allow him to wield a new
devil a devil that can see into the
future one that says he aki is going to
die in the worst
possible way and due to this will give
him some of his power in exchange for a
front row seat to his own death how
screwed up is that all that depressing
stuff aside the training with power and
dengy is super fun dozens and dozens of
fail attacks on this special division
leader later and the team of denji and
power are after trying everything that
came to them naturally and in a cute bit
of character collaboration they jointly
come up with a plan to instead and i
quote fight him using our minds with
denzi's response to this idea being like
how cool would it be if we could fight
like one of those brainy guys in manga
and stuff this my friends is the caliber
of strategic introspection we're seeing
now so naturally i wasn't expecting much
but the plan that they do eventually
come up with was actually kind of
brilliant
[Music]
overall despite this operation ending in
a big fat loss this dude gives them
props for their efforts this effort
being their best to date however it does
end with this scary dude letting them
into a false sense of security before
teaching them yet again another lesson
beasts don't trust hunters which again i
could choose to read as another indirect
suggestion to denji that he shouldn't
trust makiba the training continues
until eventually denji shows his
gratitude to him and interestingly this
is the last lesson that this individual
teaches denji who once he shows his
teacher gratitude entices him to never
accept him as a pupil ever again he only
trained denji because he thought he was
inhuman but in this moment it now
doesn't seem to be the case and he
reveals this decision to step away from
denji and power's training in an
honestly unsettling scene between
himself and makima the subject matter
within this scene is that of him
questioning makima's allegiance to the
agency with some wonderful imagery
depicting how untrusting and distant she
feels to him ending on an uncomfortable
close-up of makima's face so okay theory
time my theory is
makima doesn't have humanity's best
interests at heart at least not in the
way that humanity and this dude
specifically would consider the best
interests of humanity though i'm sure
she does in her own mind think that she
does through her we've learned about
what makes devils tick with her being
drawn specifically to those like denji
that sounds scary and dangerous
specifically because the more terrified
a particular concept like a chainsaw or
a gun can instill into society at large
the more power and influence they
potentially could have on society makima
herself has demonstrated a fascination
with power and she's demonstrated that
she herself is capable of some truly
horrific acts this dude asks makima in
this scene if she is on humanity's side
and perhaps and this could be a stretch
but perhaps he's asking her this because
she herself isn't human and the only
reason i wonder this is because this
individual this person that was training
denji stopped training denji when he
felt that humanity emerged from him he
couldn't treat another human like the
way that he's been treating denji and
perhaps in this instance he's finding it
difficult to trust makima because she
herself isn't a human or at the very
least isn't showing human tendencies
perhaps makima herself has her own
ulterior motives concerning influence
and subjugation in the same way she
wants to manipulate denji like a dog it
seems like particularly in the scene
after this where she talks directly with
the yakuza themselves she tells us as
readers more about herself and her value
system she says and i quote your
necessary evil is just an excuse to
justify your own crimes those excuses
are unnecessary to society which tells
me that she's doing everything because
she believes it's the best for society
that's a real totalitarian way of
looking at the situation when you ignore
the context of the scene somewhat and
extrapolate it out into a personal
belief of hers it made me wonder what
she might actually be capable of as she
hands over a bag filled with the eyes of
the yakuza's family members perhaps
innocent family members it makes me
wonder how many eyes she has on the rest
of the world pun definitely intended or
maybe fujimoto is totally screwing with
me and this is exactly what he wants me
to think i don't know but i digress
everything that's taken place in this
arc from the initial onslaught by the
yakuzan katana man to the counter attack
by makima to denji and power engaging
and training to makima pushing the
yakuza into a corner all culminates in
one final battle between this sect of
the yakuza versus this new special
division in the devil hunter agency one
that begins as the new division
infiltrates this building during this
section we as an audience are introduced
to a host of new characters including
the likes of the violence fiend the
spider devil which looks horrifying and
i'm not even scared of spiders the shark
fiend who let me tell you gets very good
in the next arc and finally the angel
devil a mysterious and unique devil that
isn't hostile towards humans one that if
you come into contact with them will
shorten your lifespan aki takes the
charge with this particular group's
infiltrating of the thick zombie
blockade there are of course the
instances where aki demonstrates his
lack of consideration towards his own
well-being with him coming concerningly
close to the angel devil however that's
not the aspect of this encounter i find
interesting it's instead the description
that this is a unique type of devil that
isn't hostile towards humans and again
this is just my theory but perhaps the
level of hostility a particular devil
feels towards humans is directly
correlated with how scared of that
particular concept that devil represents
to society at large for instance many
people are terrified of guns but not
many are scared of angels and so perhaps
the level of hostility is comparable
just a thought for now aki vs ghost
devil the first interesting ruffle to
show itself upon the initial insurgents
operations comes by way of hayakawa's
both literal and metaphorical
confrontation with a ghost from the past
the very ghost devil that he may know
wielded for the benefit of him is now
the one he needs to overcome and take
down and it's here i find myself needing
to remind myself of why hayakawa is
important to the story to ground it
while the story of chainsaw man itself
through the likes of denji power and
makima paint a rather nonchalant inhuman
or silly story aki is also there to
represent what's at stake the love
humans share for each other the humanity
of this world with the very message he
may know leaves behind for him to read
cutting not only to the core of his
story but further reinforcing what this
line of work and perhaps world is
forcing him to be a fearless killing
machine with his zero fear approach
literally granting him the ability to
slay this devil standing in his way this
is all to say that aki is perhaps one of
the best handled characters i've seen in
the story and one i have adored to
follow throughout so far
denji vs katana man as power
goes off to do her thing the fight that
takes place is actually surprisingly
short in comparison to other fights in
this series but that's not to say that
nothing of note or interest occurs
within there is plenty and for me less
is more in this fight specifically when
we've already sort of seen some of this
already with this being the first
rematch of the series so to speak for
denji to deal with it should go without
saying that the panel layouts work
supremely effectively it not only
conveying the action moment to moment
but also the narrative when it rears its
head across the bout quote a beast
should never trust a hunter is such an
instance of this occurring this
particular phrase that denji recalls
from his training arc acts for the
impetus behind his decisive winning blow
luring katana man into a false sense of
security seizing his chance to use these
chainsaw powers in a way that we've not
yet seen with the panels helping to
effectively deliver that surprise to us
as readers when we discover what in fact
took place there's plenty of
introspective and human moments from
katana man towards the start of this
battle however by the end he's used in a
way that i didn't see coming
following their respective fights denji
and hayakawa reconvene by the train
tracks in a surprisingly sweet moment of
connection they both get to share in a
moment of admittedly immature but much
needed humanity and therapy if you can
even call it that taking turns to kick
katana man in the nuts for what he's
done to them both over the course of
this arc fujimoto also makes a subtle
nod to the requiem scene in hunter
hunter only instead of a murder
orchestra we have a requiem composed
with the screams brought on by nutshots
truly
it's a work of art
and finally to finish off this act we
have what all of these arc so far seem
to be ending with and that's an intimate
encounter or excursion with bakima with
this epilogue specifically concerning
denji and makima's relationship on their
very first date makima's words not mine
and it's probably the most we actually
get to see of makima acting as a human
being following the victory with katana
man and her poster child denji staying
at her good graces she now has enough
material to locate the gun devil himself
which on its own is interesting but
additionally lends more context to why
she decided to go on a date with denji
in the first place additionally and
prior to her offer to go on the date
together denji has a rather strange
dream a dream where he hears pochita's
voice behind a doorway a doorway that
he's told not to open no matter what now
that's some suspenseful stuff right
there perhaps good symbolism that i'm
not aware of yet but the date itself
however
is really strange that follows makima is
dressed not in her usual severe and
uniformed attire here she seems like a
regular girl and she decides that their
date is going to be a movie hopping
marathon within the night they see three
films two of which they don't really
connect to at all leading denji to
believe that maybe movies aren't his
thing that is until the third film where
makima reassures him that he might like
it as she does like this one also both
of them together crying in the theater
share a rather genuine moment in this
instance a moment within which denji
finally starts to feel human it's
intimate it's kind of nice and it's
their best interactions so far i reckon
and just as i feel like i'm starting to
understand makima the next act pulls the
rug right out from beneath my feet and
changes
everything
the explosive mega waifu arc primarily
the story concerning that of chainsaw
men seems to be following denji and what
he's concerned with in the here and now
he doesn't seem to be someone that's
troubled by what looms ahead or by
external factors out of his control but
instead by what's immediately in front
of him and due to this despite the
agency having the necessary pieces to
locate the gun devil himself there's
little involvement of that storyline in
this short but brilliant arc reinforcing
the notion that this is a story about
the manipulation of denji it follows
dengue's most intimate moment with
makima with another encounter with a
brand new lady in his life rezay i only
notice this now but the interaction
between the two of them is initiated by
her saying he denji looked like her dead
dog to which he then performs a gross
but kinda sweet trick to cheer her up
there are so many damn dog parallels in
this story it's crazy the contrast
between this new but budding
relationship and the relationship he has
with makima should be abundantly
apparent from the get-go rezay seems to
vie for denji's affection she
compliments him constantly but i think
more than anything else this story or
section feels exceptionally authentic
rezay has a job she gets reprimanded she
admittedly has flaws she takes risks
she's forward where machiavelli would
feel to me like an alien or robot trying
to pass as a human rezai seems to be a
genuine and sweet girl that wants to get
to know denji more which makes what
happens later all the more crazy rezay
invites denji into her school after
hours to just hang out with him it feels
very intimate natural and the way it's
shot lit and presented through panels
feels personal and warm it's unlike any
of the scenes or sequences in the story
so far particularly the ones that he
shared with mockiman which is exactly
what we need to feel as readers as that
is exactly what denji is experiencing
right now too priming us for this
question from rezay when she asked denji
hey dingy which would you choose the
town mouse or the country mouse the
country mouse gets to live in safety but
doesn't get to eat delicious food like
they have in the city the town mouse
gets to eat delicious food but runs a
higher risk of getting caught by humans
and cats i really like this question i
like it first of all because it helps to
set up what rezdy ultimately builds
herself up to ask denji later on but
more broadly unlikely because it's the
theme that ties the a and b plots
together denji and aki's plots
respectively it's a question that cuts
to the core of what denji and all the
others want out of life do they want it
simple and easy or are they willing to
take greater risks if it means they get
a greater reward and naturally but to
raise a surprise denji responds with the
town mouse it's very natural and i'm
sure fujimoto wants us as readers to
focus on denji being the mouse and what
he wants in this instance and true to
form fujimoto does keep denji in line
with what he vowed for his dog to live
the best life he can to fly by the seat
of his pants it's reflected in the
answer he gave however what i find
interesting in this positive dilemma are
the two other characters that feature
beside the mouse in the story
the human and the cat
which segues nicely into this
rezai goes off to the restroom following
this conversation when suddenly she's
pursued by a maniac walking the halls
she runs she runs frantically up the
stairs onto the roof the storm rages on
as the man looking to leverage razei to
get to dengi makes his attack
[Music]
holy [ __ ] speaking an entirely different
language she puts this man to rest it
seems that we found a proverbial cat in
this story of mice and what do cats do
they
stalk but then chainsaw man's resident
shark boy shows up to make the damn save
on denji holy [ __ ] that was awesome out
of nowhere the story in the blink of an
eye or the explosion of a young girl's
head turns into a cat and mouse chase
pardon the pun through the streets of
this city as she stalks her prey
feverishly and that brings us to reze vs
denchi this is the best fight in the
series i've seen and it's not even close
the chasing conflict that stems from
this encounter lasts an entire volume
and from the start to finish of this
volume vol 6 it's utterly spectacular
boasting new characters getting to see
some of them in the spotlight some
established characters getting involved
also while in addition to finding the
space and time for gags here and there
manages to reinvent what a fight could
look like in the chainsaw man universe
by naturally exploring what genji's
powers truly are creating for us as
readers some of the most bonkers
full-page spreads that harken back and
clearly took inspiration from some of
the very best in all of the manga
industry like this one from berserk the
composition is practically identical
it's clear that fujimoto is a student of
the past greats of manga and nowhere is
that more evident than in this fight
there's just so much going on in terms
of layouts illustration and even
character with reza herself much like
she did during her fake dates with denji
she teaches him how to better control
and apply his powers through examples
and misdirection to tell you the truth
there's so much to this fight that going
moment to moment would take me another
hour to explain which my editors and i
cannot afford so i'll try to keep it
brief i think above all else this arc
and rudy this fight wants to talk about
the people that get caught up in the
crossfires of war the necessary residual
damages or casualties as superpowers or
those who make the decisions continue to
quarrel and clash dengy in this arc is
nothing more than a well-intentioned
albeit dangerous child colliding with
another tormented soul the likes of
which doesn't know to what degree she
has been manipulated denji defeats this
foe in reza with the help of aki who was
willing to throw everything away because
in the moment he didn't want to take
advantage of his comrades despite those
very higher ups offering him the chances
and powers to make those decisions and
in addition to that denji someone who
have every opportunity to manipulate or
gain some leverage here chooses not to
kill her chooses not to hand her in but
to see her go free he chooses this and
moments from making the decision to
share a genuine moment with denji she
unable to make that connection flees and
just as the curtain falls on this short
but fascinating arc makima never to be
second fiddle never to be outdone or
outplayed
enters the frame cornering
i didn't mention this earlier but in
chapter 41 mahima says something that i
found to be quite telling in that
chapter while talking to aki about his
relationship to the angel devil she says
the following you don't have to like him
all you need to do is use him for your
own benefit mahima doesn't see people as
human beings with feelings or
comprehensive understandings of their
surroundings but instead pawns in her
complicated game of chess and so it
makes me wonder was reza ever as
horrible as she alluded to others that
she was she certainly had done terrible
things in her life killed many
individuals and acquired a laundry list
of specialities across a no doubt
harrowing career working for her
superiors but it makes me wonder was
reza ever really the cat i thought she
once was was she the one pulling her own
strings or was she like denji simply
another humble manipulated and coerced
mouse struggling to find her place in
the big city someone that despite her
lies
may have unbeknownst to her had so much
more in common with denji than she ever
realized a mouse that desperately wanted
to escape to the countryside
fujimoro leaves that up to us the
audience to judge for ourselves whether
that is or is not the case but either
way mahima stands on another level
entirely towering uncaring and merciless
above the mice she manipulates
blissfully unaware of what it is she has
in store for them
next week is the last review of chainsaw
man i hope to see you there thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
you